اغلق المتظاهرون اسرانيون الطرق المؤديه
الى مطالب في تل ابيب ضمن تحركات
الاحتجاجيه تحت عنوان مقاومه الديكتاتوريه
ترفض مشروع الحكومه لتعديل النظام القضائي
داخليه مع تصعيد الاسرائيليه
صدر احداثها عن وزير الدفاع الامريكي خلال
زياره الحاليه
اهلا بكم كان ذلك الخبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه ما هي حيث
اشكال الازمه الداخليه التي تواجهها حكومه
اليمين المتطرف بالقياده في اسرائيل وكيف
انعكست على سلوك سلوك قوات الاحتلال
وتصعدها ضد الفلسطينيين وما حقيقه حجم
ضغوط التي تقول واشنطن انها تمارسها على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه للحيلوله دون التصعيد
لتركيز على مواصفاته واشنطن بانشطه
وما هي مالات المشهد في المنطقه في ضوء
استمرار العنف وعمليات الاغتيال والاعتقال
وهذا بمنازل الفلسطينيين دون اي افق
للتهدئه وايجاد حل عادلا للقضيه
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
وجد رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
حلا يصل به الى مطار بن غوريون فركب
مروحيه طارت به فوق الطرق التي اغلقها
المحتجون على سياسته والتي يرونها تقود
البلاد لدكتاتوريه وقيمه العواقب لكنه لم
يجد حلا ويدرك ان الخروج من الازمه
السياسيه الحاليه التي تردد فيها النخوه
السياسيه في اسرائيل اصعب بكثير
تعمل معارضه
من خلال اعتماد اسلوب الفوضى التهاب رد
عليه زعيم المعارضه
وقال انه يتراس فريقا حكوميا ليعملوا على
تحويل اسرائيل الى دوله متطرفه غير
ديمقراطيه هذه الازمه لا تفسد لتصعيد
الاسرائيلي ضد الفلسطينيين وقد اوقعت
عمليات اسرائيليه من الشهداء والجرحى بين
الفلسطينيين دون ان تلقى تلك العمليات
بالا او ان تلقي ابا لدعوات الامريكيه
وغربيه للتهدئه فقد الوزير الدفاع
الامريكي في بدايه زيارته الاسرائيلي
واشنطن من تصاعد العنف عنف المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين ضد الفلسطينيين كما تحدث عن
خشيه الاداره الامريكيه من ان يلهي تصعيد
في ضفه تل ابيب على الانتباه الكامل
لمواجهه ايران وسياساتها في المنطقه اما
فارس وقدعت الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى حمايه
المدنيين الفلسطينيين في ظل تصاعد العنف
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تل ابيبه
دكتور
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بار ايلان
والباحث في شهور الشرق الاوسط ومن النصر
الدكتور سليم بريكه
بالجامعه المفتوحه في حيفا والخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه وابدا بمرض خائعه
ضيفنا من تل ابيب
هنالك تصريحات نتنياهو وتصريحات اخرى
يعود باسرائيل الى دوله مسيونيه متطرفه
رساليه
مسكونه بهواجس تفوق اليهود على غيرهم من
الامم كيف تقرا هذه التصريحات تصريحات
ورد
لها الخاصه بان المعارضه فقط تريد اسقاط
الحكومه
في مصاب بضعف الذاكره لانه عندما
كانوا في حكومه
بنفس اسلوب نتنياهو في هذه الايام
المشكله اليوم في اسرائيل هي مشكله
التوازن بين الكنيست والحكومه من جانب
والمنظومه الخدعيه من جانب اخر ما حدث في
سنوات الاخيره هو
القضائيه استولت على الكنيست وعلى الحكومه
والان الكنيست والحكومه تريد ازاله هذا
هذه الديكتاتوريه لبعض القضاه
واعاده الدوله الى الشاكله الديمقراطيه
اراد
عندما كان وزيرا
ولكن اليوم هو في المعارضه وكذلك هو يعارض
كل ما يكون به او حكومه بريطانيه والكنيسه
التي هي اليوم تميل الى اليمين بسبب
تصرفات الفلسطينيه
تميل الى اليمين بسبب تصرفات الفلسطينيين
وهنا ياتي السياق اخر لحظه واحده هناك
سياق اخر يتزامن مع هذه الازمه الداخليه
يعني الفلسطينيون لم يقولوا
الاسرائيلي ان يخرجوا بهذه الاعداد وان
يسدوا الطرق لا شك في هذا لكن
من الناصره الدكتور سليم بريك هذه الازمه
الداخليه الاسرائيليه
الانقسام ما بين
مختلف التيارات الان الخاشيه حتى من ان
يكون هذا الانقسام شبيها بالانقسامات
الاتيه ادت الى زوال الدوله اليهوديه في
التاريخ من قبل
هل هل انعكس هل ما يجري في الضفه الغربيه
هو انعكاس لهذه الازمه ام انه
محاوله للهروب من هذه الازمه
مساء الخير
ولجميع المشاهدين
انا باعتقادي ما يحدث في الغربيه هو تصعيد
طبيعي لقوه احتلال التي لا تريد حل مع
فلسطين وتريد انهاء الصراع الاسرائيلي
فلسطيني بشكل احادي الجانب من غير ان تاخذ
بالاعتبار
مطالب الفلسطينيين ورغبتهم في اقامه دوله
فلسطين كما كان اتفاق في اوسلو وطبعا ما
يحدث مع الفلسطينيين عمليا تاتي ثمره ايضا
في قلب المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعني
الفاشيه التي تتطور في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
يوما بعد يوم هي عمليه
كما يعتقد البعض يعني على سبيل المثال فقط
مثال خير من الفتره الاخيره قبل
الانتخابات بشهر
يعطوا له صوره مع بنك فير الان عين وزير
الامن القومي اي انه وسع نطاقه
وعمليا هو يعطيه الفرصه شرطه اسرائيل
وليحولها عمليا لشرطه تابعه هذا امر غير
مسبوق وهذه الشرطه لا
ملاحق
ين عليه وانا ايضا حتى تلاحق اليساريين
وتلاحق كل من يعارض الانقلاب فاذا ما يحدث
في دوله اسرائيل هو شرخ عميق بين قوى
مختلفه قوه يمينيه
اسطوريه دينيه تريد ارض اسرائيل الكامله
ولا تريد ان ترى عرض في اسرائيل هو حريدين
التي تريد ان ترى دوله اسرائيل دوله
يهوديه حسب التوراه وهو ليبراليه تريد
دوله اسرائيل دوله ديمقراطيه الى حد ما
وما يحدث في الشارع
ليس هذا يعني لم نشهد كثيرا
مظاهرات سياسيه في اسرائيل
تخشى على الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل يعني
المظاهرات اسرائيل التي تابعنا في السنوات
الماضيه كانت حول غلاء الاسعار حول ما
يجري لابناء اليهود الفلاش الذين جاؤوا من
اثيوبيا وما يحدث التمييز لكن هذه هذه
المظاهرات الان وكان هنالك خشيه بالفعل
لدى سكان المدن لدى من يعتبرون يمثلون
الشق السياسي المدني في اسرائيل الابرالي
الاسرائيلي من درجات هذه الحكومه هل ترى
انت كذلك ايضا
شوف اولا
التطورات هي الروايه اسرائيليه من قديم
الزمان ونحن
نستمتع من هذه الاشياء هذا الاولاد ثانيا
ما حدث في اسرائيل في في عقود الاخيره وان
اليمين
الاسرائيلي
تزايد بسبب التكاثر السكاني بسبب عدم
مغادره البلاد بينما اليسار اختفى
بصوره شبه كامله حزمه
يعني لم يدخل في الكنيسه وحزب العمل يعني
في طريق الانطلاق ولذلك اليسار الذي خسر
الانتخابات مره والاخرى يريد التحكم
بمقاليد الدوله عبر المنظومه وهذا ما حدث
خلال عن 25 عام طيب انا اتحدث عن
المتضاريف في الشارع يعني نحن نتحدث عن
احتجاجات واسع السيد لا نتحدث عن تصريحات
سياسيه نتحدث عن طيارين رفضوا نقل رئيس
الحكومه طيارين مدنيين في شركه العالم
الاسرائيليه رفضوا نقل الرئيس الحكومه
وزوجته الى ايطاليا نتحدث عن مواطنين سدوا
الطرق تحدث عن ان وزير الدفاع الامريكي لم
يغادر مطار بن غوريون ليلتقي رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي بالمدينه اليوم وانما التقى
معه في مطار ليس هذا فعل هذا هذا اكثر من
ذلك اليس كذلك
الدوله لانها حتى الذين
طرق امام الوزير وامام الله حكومه لم
يصابوا باي شيء هم لهم القمل الحق في
التداول حتى اغلاق الطرق لا اتحدث عن ان
هذه الفضيله او هذه نقيسه انا اتحدث ماذا
تعكس ماذا يعكس ذلك الا يعكس ذلك ان هنالك
خشيه لدى قطاع كبير من الاسرائيليين ارتاد
حتى للطيارين من توجهات هذه الحكومه وان
هذه الحكومه ليست خطر على الفلسطينين
وانما هي خطر على بقيه اليهود واخيه
الاسرائيلي
اليهود في اسرائيل لا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون هذا اولا ثانيا الذين في الشارع
يخافون ويحزنون
يا اخي هم يعني يفرحون بهذه المظاهرات
لانهم لم يصب احد منهم ولا احد فرجني على
الدوله دوله اخرى
يكون فيها هذه
المظاهرات على الشوارع يعودون للبيوتهم
يعني السالمين غانمين هذه الدوله
هي تعامل حتى المتظاهرين
كل الطرق
بقفزات من الحريه
هذه يعني هذا مسموح وعالم بمت
ضايرين هم النخبه
خسرت الانتخابات مره اخرى وهي تريد البقاء
في الحكم
والكنيسه لتغيير قواعد اللعبه كايتوزين
ديكتاتوريه القدر هم في الشوارد ليحتجوا
على ان السلطه
تفرض من ايديهم هل هم كذلك دكتور سليم
بريك هل بهذه البساطه من خسر الانتخابات
نزلوا الشارع امامنا الامر اكبر من ذلك
لا طبعا هذا غير صحيح يعني هذا
تفسير سطحي جدا لما يحدث هناك الحقيقه
اولا ان اليسار عمليا لا يوجد يسار انا
اتفق مع كتابه في اسرائيل حقيقه ولكن
الجانب الاخر جانب معضله
ولكن في الاحزاب التي سقطت الان نحن نعترف
بان
نا ولكن النقاش هو على امور اخرى المواطن
في اسرائيل اولا
القلق من المحاربه او الهجوم على السلطه
القضائيه هو
قلق يعني كل الدول التي انهارت في
الديمقراطيه نرى ان الديكتاتور بدا اولا
بمحاربه جهاز القضاء والادعاء بين جهاز
القضاء يحارب الحكومه هذا حدث في اوروبا
الشرقيه هذا حدث مثلا في تونس هذا يحدث في
عده اماكن التي تنهى في هذه الديمقراطيات
الان ما يحدث في اسرائيل هو نفس النمط
هناك شعبويه يمينيه من ناحيه هناك حريدين
لا يريدون الديمقراطيه نهائيا لانها ليست
في اخلاقياتهم من ناحيه اخرى وهناك
الصهيونيه الدينيه التي تريد السيطره على
كل ارض اسرائيل من غير اي ديمقراطيه
ومحاكم من الناحيه الثالثه الان اضافتنا
لكل هذا نتنياهو بثلاث ملفات فساد رقم
اثنين في حكومه
في الاموال والى اخره اذا نحن لا نتحدث
عمليا عن وضع
حدث هناك اخرين يريدون قلب نظام الحكم هذا
اختراق القضيه الاضافيه والتي يجب ان
ناخذها في الحسبان ايضا انه هناك محاوله
لزرع الفساد وشرع الفساد في دوله اسرائيل
في
الفتره مشروع قانون يشارع الفساد بما في
ذلك قانون درع قانون
نقطه اخيره اريد ان اقولها بان
التجنيع في اسرائيل هو فعلا امر سطحي وامر
معادل الديمقراطيه تماما اولا المحكمه
العليا منذ 30 عاما حتى الان
قامت بعمريا برفض 21 قانون قسم من هذه
القوانين حتى قوانين هامشيه وليس انقلاب
على سلطه الكنيست القضيه الاضافيه انه
الحكومه في اسرائيل السلطه
التنفيذيه تسيطر تماما على السلطه
التشريعيه اضف الى ذلك انه لا يوجد
محكمه العليا الان هم يريدون تقليم اظافر
المحكمه العليا وهذا ما يقلق كل مواطنه
ومواطن في دوله اسرائيل ويجعلهم يخرجون
الى الشارع
السيد
عبرت عن خشيتها ليس
من تطورات الاوضاع فقط في الضفه الغربيه
ولكن خشت ايضا على الدين في اسرائيل
وقالت انها ستمارس ضغوطا على اسرائيل هل
ترى اي اثر او اي شكل هذه الضغوط ما طبيعه
هذه ضغوط التي تمارسه واشنطن وما هو
مردودها
اولا نذكر بان الحكم اليوم في روايات
المتحده ويسر
متطرف مع اهداف الكونكر
والرشيد الطلايم سندس هم يجرون الولايات
المتحده الى اكثر
الحكومه الرئيس اليميني
نعم ولكن اليوم الضغوط الممارسه من قبل
النظام الاداره امريكيه عليه تاتي من
اليسار الذي خسر في اسرائيل وهم يشعرون
بان دوله اسرائيل تروح الى اليمين كما
الشعب هنا الذي في اليوم اليمين اكبر من
اليسار الاسرائيلي مع العرب مجتمعي ولذلك
الامريكيون لا يريدون هذا وهم يريدون
حكومه هنا في
شعب الفكافيه ولذلك يمارسون
الدروت على وحكومته كي يعودوا الى المركز
على الاقل
ولبس يعني الغاضبون من هذا من هذا التدخل
متروك لدوله وهذه دوره ديمقراطيه للنخاع
وانا اتمنى من الامريكيين ان يستمتعوا
بالديمقراطيه
اي ضغوط امريكيه على حكومه في اي اتجاه
يعني تصريحات
استون اليوم انه
الغربيه ربما
عن ايران
نعم انا لا اعرض ضغوط حقيقيه امريكيه ولكن
فعلا الولايات المتحده قلقه مما يحدث
عمليا
الامريكان عبر المناسبه هذا كان بمبادره
يجدوا صيغه التواضع وهذا المصلحه اسرائيل
والمصلحه الفلسطينيه ولكن من قام بنصف كل
هذا هو اسمه
باي حال من الاحوال الوصول الى صدام مع
الفلسطينيه الان هل الولايات المتحده تضغط
على اسرائيل طبعا لا يعني هي
تطالبها ولكن عمليه لا يوجد اي نوع من
الضغوط انا اريد ايضا ان اقول يعني ان
استغرب واسجل حتى من يقول بان الوزن
المتحده تتدخل في الشونه الداخليه
الاسرائيلي اولا الولايات المتحده تعطي
مليارات الدولارات لاسرائيل وهي عمليا
تحميها من الناحيه الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
وبكل هذه الامور فاذا يعني قليل من ضبط
النفس يكون افضل بمعنى اسرائيل تتدخل
دائما هو بشكل سافر في الولايات المتحده
اليهود في الولايات المتحده انا اقصد طبعا
وليس الشعب اليهودي
هناك يؤيدون حزب الديمقراطي ولكن مثلا
ونحن نتذكر بعض الاغنياء في اسرائيل في
الولايات المتحده اليهود الذين وضعوا
تشيكات ودولارات ملايين الدولارات من اجل
دونالد ترامب
الذهاب الى الكونغرس اكثر من مره في فتره
اوباما وهاجم البيت الابيض وهاجم اداره
اوباما
افضل الاسرائيليين ولكن السؤال هو يتعلق
المتحده
عمليه في في اسرائيل
لكن فيما يتعلق بالازمه السياسيه
هل الولايات المتحده
ان لها يمكن ان تلعب دوره في يد
نعم اعتقادي نعم واحنا سمعنا مثلا
او قبل يومين
الذي يحذر اسرائيل من التدهور الاقتصادي
الذي ممكن ان يحدث بسبب الانقلاب وبسبب
الديكتاتوريه التي على الطريق وايضا بسبب
الميول الى الفساد يعني بشكل واضح نستطيع
ان نقول
وفيها فساد تنهار اقتصاديا هذا ممكن ان
نراه بدون كثيره في العالم ولذلك الولايات
المتحده
قد اكبر ولكن ليس اكثر من هذا
فيما يتعلق بانعكاس كل ذلك على الوضع في
المنطقه يعني هل يمكن ان يكون هنالك اي
انعكاسات لهذه الازهر على الوضع في
الاقليم
ذلك لان الاقليم سعاد
تفضل اكمل اكمل
الداخلي في صيد في واد اخر
يشوف فيما يخص المشاكل
الاقليميه هي قبل واحده هناك اشاعات بانه
التي فجرت قبل يومين
هدف في سوريا هذا ليس لم يتساور لا من
اليمين هلا اذا كان يصيد اذا كان اسرائيل
احيانا الفلسطينيين اسرائيل موحده حياله
الكثير من الامور في الشرق الاوسط ليس
هناك يمين وليس هناك يسار هناك
في شؤون الشرق الاوسط ونشكر ايضا من النصر
الدكتور سليم بريك المحاضر بالجامعه
مفتوحه في حيفا والخريف الاسرائيلي
الى هنا تنتهي الحلقه من برنامج مهر الخبر
دمتم في رعايه
[موسيقى]